In the land of Asia.
Welcome to Feathered Friends and Flight.
My name is Corey.
And I'm Katie.
All right, Logan, are you ready?
Okay, here we go.
You got this?
Logan the raven gets ready
for his big performance.
He comes out
and it's the opening of the show.
Oh. And he finds a water bottle
that was accidentally left on the stage.
And it's
going straight to the cam,
and he brings it over to the recycle bin.
He puts it in the bin, recycles it.
Yes, he got it. Good.
And that starts the show.
Why are you so good?
Good job, Roseanne.
You're so good.
We really like to feature
natural behaviors of birds
and hopefully inspire the audience
for caring conservation action.
They can see birds
from all over the world.
Logan definitely
thinks he's the star of the show.
You can tell he's extremely handsome
and he always gets really great reactions
from the crowd.
They're so smart.
They've done some research that shows
that Ravens actually plan for the future.
They're really good at problem
solving and tool use,
which is pretty amazing.
Logan's intelligence
keeps the team on their toes.
We just need a little more depth
in this routine.
Logan's always hungry for a challenge,
so they've come up with a new one.
He's going to learn how to untie knots,
starting with trainer Corey shoe laces.
He's never done anything with shoes yet.
No. Okay.
It's a really fun behavior
with a really smart bird
who I think is going to get this
pretty quick. But you never know.
Every bird is an individual,
so we'll have to see how Logan does.
All right, here comes Logan.
Okay, I'm going to spin them around here.
Just set them down on the ground.
Ready? Yep.
Good, good.
This is a fun puzzle.
You give them a puzzle
and they figure it out immediately.
Good.
That was great.
Logan nails it without breaking a sweat.
Thanks to a familiar technique.
Katie saying good.
He knows that good word
has been paired with food
so that he can know
he did the right thing.
And if he comes back to Katie, he's
going to get a treat.
That's the way
you feel that when you learn something new
and you're like, I just did that thing.
Wow, how cool is that?
It's such a good job that the birds
must have that same feeling.
Out in the wild.
They got to use their intelligence.
There are crows that have been seen
dropping things like nuts
with a really strong shell onto crosswalks
so that the cars will break them open
for them.
So they're very, very smart.
It's how they go
through their entire world.
He did awesome.
That was like it was really good.
That first training session
couldn't have gone better.
It was like he had been doing this
his whole life already.
But it doesn't just stop at the shoelace.
There is a second part to this behavior.
It's pretty complex.
I hope Logan's ready.